NAN BODEN: Good afternoon.
I'm delighted to be here today.
I know you've heard
a lot about what
we're doing in Google
Cloud on the sale's side,
on the product's side,
and some about our go
to market channels.
I'm really excited
to talk to you today
about what we've
been doing and what
we're in the process of really
building in our Tech Partner's
organization.
This organization came
together just a few months ago
to really focus on our
Tech Partners ecosystem.
And by that, we mean independent
software vendors and also
our top strategic partners.
We've been scaling
this operation.
In fact as Diane
mentioned earlier,
sometimes the rate of the
scaling is kind of dizzying.
But I want you to
understand what
our philosophy is for that.
And so, hopefully, we
can partner with you
and many of your
customers about how
we take this ecosystem forward.
So when we first
started thinking
about what it means
to partner, we
started thinking
about our principles.
And I want to run
you through those.
But then, I want to tell you
how we operationalize them.
And how I think that's
really quite different.
And how it's going to make
an even bigger difference
in what we build together.
First of all, we want
to be the open platform
and the open partner.
And you've heard that a lot
from Brian Stevens this morning
about how open we
are with respect
to things like open source.
But in this case, the openness
extends even further than that.
And I'll talk about
a couple of examples
where that openness
really changes the way
our partnering is put together.
We also want to bring more
innovation than just Google
could bring by itself.
And that's really
one of the tenets
that Diane laid out early
on about our partnering--
is that we really want to
have a much bigger innovation
story than any one company,
even a company of Google size
could build.
And building that
with our partners
is something that really
excites our engineers.
And particularly as we take
it into new applications
and new markets.
You know, fairness
and transparency
are really core
tenants of Google.
And that fairness
and transparency
when extended to
partners, I think
gives us a real strong
competitive advantage
in that people want to
partner with Google,
because we're going to
be fair and transparent
and bring innovation
to a bigger market.
And all of that results
in a shared success.
And Diana said it very often,
that our success is really
our partner's success.
If our partners
are not successful,
you know, then it's really
just academic what we're doing.
And so, we've really
been focusing a lot
on, not just the technical
and the integration
parts of how we work
with our partners,
but what are the
business models?
How do we make sure
that they're successful?
How do we split
that value that we
create in the world in a
fair and appropriate way,
so that we can sustain
more and more of this?
So some of this I know seems
kind of uncontroversial,
like who would vote
against these things?
But when we really start
to operationalize it,
some really cool things happen.
We looked very early on
at some of the thinking
that-- very typical
stuff that goes on.
Let's say, we've got a new
idea out there in the world,
should I build or
should I partner?
And that build or
partner can really
be a kind of long
and painful thought.
You know, like should I?
I don't know.
Maybe I should build,
maybe I should partner.
And what we decided was
this is really the wrong way
to think about it.
If you're really the open
partner and the open platform,
you should do both or you
should be open to doing both.
That we should
build and partner.
And that's been a really
liberating concept for us,
not just in terms of what
we're able to do with partners,
but also our internal
product teams.
You know, they
understand they don't
have to build every single
feature everybody thought of.
We can wind up
doing things where
we cover much more of the
innovation and market space
by doing both.
So recently, we've had two
really exciting examples
of that.
You've heard of some this
morning from Evernote
and also a deal we
just had with Box.
These are very clear examples
of the strategy where Google
has products in each
of these spaces,
but there's a very
big world out there
and a huge, huge
number of customers
who prefer Box and who prefer
Evernote for their needs.
And when we partner together, we
create a much bigger ecosystem.
And so, each of
them has been using
different points
of what Google has
to offer in terms of products
and technology, from G Suite
to Cloud to Springboard
search and assist
and also all of our machine
learning techniques.
And so, if you think about
this model for how even though
Google may now or
may in the future
have a product in
a certain space,
it's still a wide open field for
how we can innovate together.
Just as exciting
for that is how, not
just the things in Google
Cloud that we bring,
but if you think about the
entire portfolio of what Google
has to offer in products
and technologies.
One of the best
things that I've found
in the sort of three
short months we've
been doing this new
organization for Tech Partners,
has been that our friends
in other parts of Google,
like in AdWords and Analytics,
and Play, and YouTube-- I mean,
they're super excited
about us being
able to partner
with other companies
to really bring what
is the power of one
Google to those markets.
And really to innovate in not
just technology, but in the way
the business is put together.
To transform industries.
And that's something that
my organization is just
on fire with how
exciting it is to be
able to work on these
things with our partners.
I'm blessed with a
great number of members
of my team, who are both
engineers, and MBAs,
and business people,
and BD folks.
And just putting
that all together
in a way that basically
moves the needle forward.
Certainly for us and
for our partners,
it's just been
tremendously exciting.
We look at a different ISVs by
a bunch of different sectors.
And so, there's
all kinds of ways
to intergage with Google
about our organization,
about how you go
about partnering.
And so, we have experts
in each of these areas.
If you're in data and
analytics in the Cloud
or if you're in
visualization, we
have a lot of different
programs for each of those.
And so, it's been a
really exciting time
to put that together and
start to really take that out
to market.
And you're starting to see
deals that we're announcing.
And of course, we're
working on a lot more.
The other thing
that we're doing is
we're investing in
the infrastructure
for our partners.
And the acquisition
that we did recently
of Orbitera, which is an
e-commerce Cloud platform,
multi-cloud back end.
They provide really
nice test drives
and one of the more
elegant billing systems
that I've seen certainly on
the cloud platforms-- you know,
for being able to handle
all the major public clouds.
I mean, the Orbitera
platform allows our ISVs
to plug into that.
And then, it really
simplifies their ability
to deploy and have
their customers use
any of the clouds.
And this is something
that we want
to lower that friction
for our partner,
so especially the ISVs can
get to market faster, and be
able to deliver their
services, and grow
their businesses better.
The other thing you
heard earlier today
was the acquisition of Apigee.
One of the things
that I really enjoy
about thinking through
how this is going
to affect our partners--
is that, if you
use one of Apigee's,
I think, really
illustrative examples of one
of their customers, Walgreens,
you can see how this
kind of framework
can help us move partnering and
the integration of applications
forward much faster.
This example shows
Walgreens that
may have started with the
idea of, oh, hey look.
I can do a photo prints
API, wouldn't that be great?
You know, because
now we can just
print photos with an API call.
And over time, they
grew to say, well,
you know not only do I
need to print photos and be
able to do just
that with an API,
what about my prescriptions?
You know, I can have
folks be able to refill
their prescriptions
with an API and I can
do my rewards program that way.
And before you know
it, especially when
they announced this
to the outside world,
all of a sudden you have
Imager and Instagram
trying to print photos.
And you have WebMD hooked up
to their prescription's APIs.
And that framework for
being able to integrate now
hundreds of APIs
quickly and securely
and be able to make sure that
there's not any kind of falling
over as you try
to scale, is what
I think allows us to have a
framework that our partners can
really build some exciting
applications-- in a way that
really gets them
to market quickly
and allows us to
put things together
that might have been too
hard to do in other ways.
So I'm very excited about
both of these acquisitions,
because they allow
our partners to be
a lot more successful quicker.
And that's the
thing that we want
to use going forward as we
try to build even deeper tech
partnerships.
So the message of
the story today
is that we've really been taking
a different view to partnering
certainly than Google's had
available in and around Cloud.
We took several groups
and put them together
in terms of groups that were
already doing some partnering.
Gave them a much bigger
scope, a much bigger mission.
And tripled the
size of the group.
And we are really on
fire with how well we
want to go about doing things
that really make a difference.
And so, if you think about
partnering with Google,
particularly on the
tech partnering side,
I can tell you for sure, now is
the time that you should really
be doing that
investigation with us.
Because it just
seems like there's
so many things to be
going at here in terms
of really bringing
innovation to our customers
and really transforming
industries.
So we are open for business
and we would certainly
love to talk to folks about
how to do more tech partnering.
Thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]